we got
what we wanted people deadpool 3
will be rated r so excited
that feige himself has confirmed this
i'm very excited about this as obviously
we've been one of the people who've been
like it look if you're going to do this
if you're going to do this
feige this has to be rated r don't
[ __ ] with us talking with someone i
forget who he said
it will be rated r and we are working on
a script right now and
ryan's overseeing a script right now i
like how he just like from the way he
read it
you read this it just sounds so like
like a matter of fact yeah it's gonna be
great
why would you questions
it doesn't make it's such like a big
thing that was with this movie is it's
going to be an m2 they're going to still
keep you ready
that's that's been such a talk about it
can we still trust that deadpool will be
ready to heart he just yeah we'll be
ready
this could have been an announcement
yeah this could have been a whole press
release this could have been it some
kind of gala or whatever
this could have been disney investor day
saying and we are doing deadpool 3 and
yes
it will be raided or like that would
have blown the roof off
and then in here it's just so
matter-of-fact it's something to spice
up january
it will not be filming this year which
is unfortunate
ryan is a very busy very successful
actor
um what else does he have going that's
as big as
free guy gonna be huge the hit man's
body
six underground i feel like i'll be huge
i feel like all that could be
put on hold just for him to do deadpool
yeah
we've got a number of things we've
already announced that we now have to
make
but it's exciting for it to have begun
again a very different type of character
in the mcu and ryan is a force of nature
which is just awesome to see him bring
that character to life that's really
cool
it's fun hearing about this because he's
making it's like it's ryan reynolds film
you know it's not like oh yeah you know
the foggy mcu
stamp will be all over it we got ryan
working on it because it's usually he's
talking about like with black math or
two he's talking about ryan coogler's
working on this or this person's working
on this
and you rarely hear about the
development process of a movie
when it's about the star of the suit
you're like yeah we got the star
attached but we got this director and
writer working on it and it's kind of
cool to hear him talking about ryan
reynolds as the main guy
shepherding deadpool 3 for the mcu it's
pretty neat no absolutely
different and it fits i mean with the
legacy of deadpool thus far because i
mean if anything ryan reynolds has been
the champion has been the face has
been the voice that brought that like he
leaked the footage that made this all
happen
so uh yeah it seems like he's in a
unique position for the mcu to just be
able to call his own shots as probably
much as anybody could who's not kevin
feige yeah
money people what kim fighters been
doing is going around doing press
since one division is coming out this
week so someone did ask
we know with from deadline we know with
monica rambo her character connects into
captain marvel 2 and that the series
connects to doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
is one division a ramp to the revival of
x-men
you're planning kevin feige goes on to
give a fighty answer
these are all like honestly that
deadpool answer is one of the
rare straightforward answers i've ever
gotten from five
cloaking it wasn't like you know it
could be rated r it might not
be rated r just saying it could be
either or kevin feige out that's usually
how
feige answers his questions he's like
maybe it is maybe it isn't
let's find out we'll let the wind see
it says every answer clever kind of way
so he says here like this is a very
direct question
is one division a ramp to the revival of
x-men you're planning in hindsight
in five years if when we're talking
about everything that's happened
everything can be a ramp to everything
specifically though
yes yeah i don't know right you know in
hindsight
it just gets all philosophical about
this this all did lead to end game
didn't it monica and captain marvel too
and specifically to want to team it up
with doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
like what that doesn't answer the
question what the hell are you saying
what are you saying exactly the answer
the former question you didn't answer
the latter
yeah you're just reconfirming what we
already know about the connectivity with
dr
strange and i'm sure yeah and playing
very nice and coy
that's one of those rumors that i bet is
probably
well within the works but he doesn't
want to touch it yeah yeah but i think
it is a big question to ask
i imagine that's a big part of what's
going to be happening with the
multiverse here because when he was
talking with comicbook.com and being
asked about the multiverse and
spider-man he said this
i've read some things i'm not sure i've
read all things
here we go again
i haven't read a hundred percent of the
rumors
the fun thing about online speculation
when it comes to our stuff is how it
sometimes
it couldn't be more off the mark and
sometimes it's shockingly close isn't it
and that's all true for the last few
years
but same witches which would take all
the fun out of everything at least he
acknowledges why he does the feige talk
yeah why because part of the marvel
charm it's part of the fun because you
know that part of what he's saying is
yes you just have no idea which
yes he's saying talking about the rumors
this this automatically makes
a lot of people go like so some of it
might be true some of it's true right
tobias is
yeah that's that's where the mindset
goes the way he phrases it i'm like well
what's gonna mean none of it's true guys
this is gonna be enough
hundred percent of it how all rumors in
the film industry
must work because some of the scoops are
good some of them aren't when talking
about this
he did go on to elaborate a little bit
more
because they were talking about the
multiverse specifically then i want to
tie this back to that x-men question
from
comicbook.com says as for the multiverse
of it all as many expect to see
it seems the storyline of a multiverse
which was once fabled by mysterio and
spider-man far from home is going to
become a true theory in the mcu in one
way or another and here's what he said
the biggest clue is the title of the
second dr strange movie that's the
biggest clue of where
the multiverse of madness is taking us
and how we're exploring that it's
surreal to me that we're talking about a
spider-man 3 i worked on a movie called
spider-man 3 many years ago directed by
mr sam raimi
so this clearly the shorthand i'm
calling spider-man 3 now it's fine
we call it homecoming three ah so that's
not the actual title right that's just
the working title
let's before we get our hope coming
three
things with the spiderman out and
everything yeah
it's only homecoming three and he's
really pointing to the title of
multiverse amazing guys the clue's been
here the whole time
when talking about all the theories and
speculation and especially hearing how
one division it's inspired by many
comics many graphic novels and some of
its own original takes are going to be
doing and a lot of people are mainly
pointed towards the house of m and i do
think it would be a cool flipparoo
because house of m it's not a spoiler
for wanda vision because
most of house of m like that deals with
mainly mutants throughout it and at the
end of it no more mutants so we'll be
kind of a cool switcheroo
if this does is is inspired by house of
m
the tone the reality warping and all
that providing us with the
the perfect life because that's what
happens in house of m everyone gets this
perfect life after she does reality
warping like their their best wishes
come true as you can see probably just
in the trailers that's what's happening
but it would be
neat if there's is that flip where oh
instead of getting rid of the mutants
she brings in all the mutants yeah i
think that's why he's especially dodging
x-men questions this time around that's
obviously all speculation but i believe
that's a big part of it especially
with the fact that the wanda and vision
tale is so tied in with mutants that
this does seem like the perfect time to
do it
the fact that they do have one division
doctor strange and spider-man 3
all dealing with multiverse consequences
it just seems likely that this is the
time for the mutants to start coming in
and i mean you could do a lot of really
fun teasing and whatnot and i mean he
said that they've taken some inspiration
from and notes from the mandalorian and
how they've put out their show and
that's one that definitely
crosses over into very very significant
lore brings back on occasion very
significant characters or plot lines and
whatnot and so
you know even if it doesn't become the
focus of one division it definitely
seems like a prime
opportunity to introduce that side of
the world and
you know a way to make it x-men exciting
potentially without making it only
focused on oh the review of the x-men
and everything else gets overshadowed
you know it seems like a nice jumping
off point and i bet
you know it's cool that he i i didn't
realize that
feige was involved at all with
spider-man 3 sam raimi's but him
bringing that up it does make my marvel
fan boy mine go
are you alluding to the fact that toby
maguire is indeed returning
would you be why would you bring up that
movie
why this was giving i get the actual you
know
the sentence on paper but what's the
deeper meaning behind this is that way
bunch of villains in that movie bunch of
villains come into this movie
it's cool that one division has now
become the promotional game
to ramp up for all of our like the last
thing i was really hearing about in the
press it was
mainly about savior so what about after
one division
this is the new marvel right here from
home until the theater's open
but mainly guys are you excited that
deadpool 3
is in fact rated r are you excited about
that leave your thoughts down below ah
i am i really am and um yeah
what do you think about stuff subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button catch you guys soon oh yeah
and keep looking for our one division
reactions